[Musica]
ciao a tutti quando si sale su questo
palco e prima si viene chiamati per
parlare di futuro
e si arriva qui ci si dice ma chissà se
le persone che sono di fronte a me
pensano che io abbia delle soluzioni in
tasca ho delle idee da proporre proprio
adesso
beh la risposta è no non ce l'ho però in
tasca o qualcosa che è una penna
che è la numero 18
con cui ho scritto la bozza degli
appunti per chiacchierare con voi oggi
per condividere alcuni pensieri che
penso possano essere interessanti
questa numero 18 chiaramente non è una
penna caso ha una storia una storia
recente
dei miei cari amici che producono queste
penne in italia mi hanno anche su una
gentilezza e cioè di parlare con la loro
figlia che doveva scegliere il percorso
universitario
perché era molto confusa
fate attenzione
scegliere un percorso universitario per
uno studente vuol dire iniziare a
scegliere a fare le prime scelte
importanti per la propria vita
e chiaramente come tutti i genitori
questi gestori erano in ansia perché poi
c'è stato questa emergenza sanitaria
insomma non è facile e quindi mi ha
telefonato a tutti chiedo una cortesia
puoi parlare tu con lei perché crediamo
che una chiacchierata con te potrebbe
essere molto interessante soprattutto
chiarirle delle cose e anche un po il
mio lavoro questo molto volentieri
questa ragazza che si chiama vividi
arriva la prima cosa sono molto agitata
perchè chiaro no io sono anche un
genitore oltre che essere una persona
che si occupa di educational università
eccetera e quindi mi dice guarda io non
so che cosa dire perché sono molto
confusa questo succeda tutti noi non
essere soltanto chi deve scegliere
università e io ho le dico ok tranquilla
serena ti faccio una domanda partiamo da
zero cancella tutto quello che senti ti
hanno detto e oggi hanno riletto
eccetera eccetera 0 ferma c'è qualcosa
che ti rende ed è veramente felice e mi
ha guardato male tu cosa c'entra con
l'università
io feci contenta se centrasse detto
guarda fai un esercizio con me
dimenticati che cosa si aspettano gli
altri da te che cosa dovresti fare per
trovare lavoro che cosa tutto quello che
ti hanno detto di pensare per scegliere
università
beh mi ha fatto una che kurt un'oretta è
uscita con gli occhi che brillavano
eccetera eccetera è i suoi genitori mi
hanno regalato questa penna
questa penna però in realtà io l'avevo
scelto in un momento in cui sono andato
con un amico ritirava una sua penna
perché perché la storia nella storia
dice che
nella mia famiglia io ho un fratello
più grande
a 18 anni
oppure al diploma oppure alla laurea era
sia la solita regalare quindi scegli una
penna importante
più questa penna non ho mai ricevuta
eppure le altre cose le ho fatte ma
appena verranno vai regalata
posso dirvi mi è rimasto un po qua
pari passo e quindi giorno di qualche
neanche tanto tempo fa in cui l'ho vista
ma in mano a questa signora che è quella
che l'ha creata
miss aperto il cuore e quindi le ho
chiesto posso avere quella penna e lei
mi ha guardato certo che poi e poi mi
hanno contattato dicendomi ci sono dei
numeri perché come sapete le pene di un
certo tipo sono contrassegnate da un
numero ce ne producono solo un certo 9
ce n'era un sacco di casualmente c'era
il numero 18 questa è la penna 18 con
cui ho scritto la bozza così gli appunti
dell'intervento di oggi
allora intanto io sono anche laureati in
design della comunicazione e quindi oggi
potrei portare via le slide e vi faccio
vedere frizzi lazzi
video e quant'altro no
oggi facciamo un ragionamento più snello
e usiamo le parole invece che usare
tanto le immagini perché forse perché le
immagini ci danno molta forza e molto
emozione ma ci tolgono qualcosa cioè
l'ascolto
abbiamo un quarto d'ora quindi non è un
tempo lunghissimo proviamo a ragionare
su questo la visione
io sono sempre stata chiamata in tutte
le mie esperienze drammatiche per questo
tipo di talento per la visione che
riesco a vedere dei contesti diversi
l'educational arte contemporanea il
cinema sono stato anche presidente del
museo nazionale del cinema tra tutte le
cose
che cosa vuol dire avere visione vuol
dire togliere togliere toglie le
togliere togliere fino a che rimane
l'essenziale e come diceva il papa del
piccolo principe l'essenziale è visibile
e invisibile agli occhi e quindi e
quindi si toglie fino a che non senti
che rimane solo l'essenziale è chiaro
che io sto parlando
dopo 20 anni di esperienze di un certo
tipo ma ho iniziato da zero
quando ho iniziato da zero
ho iniziato
quasi da zero dopo gli studi di una
grande agenzia internazionale di
corporate e brand image mi ha chiamato
il presidente ho mangiato tre curriculum
che non potevano dire molto di me ho
finito di studiare in due università da
poco tempo
mi hanno mandato tre curriculum mi hanno
richiamato le tre agenzie e uno mia
assunta subito era il secondo colloquio
e qualcuno mi ha domandato ma non ti
sentivi
è agitata da questo questo diciamo così
grandi ruoli che ti hanno dato
immediatamente perché uno può rispetto
alle responsabilità può anche essere in
agitazione non sentirsi all'altezza la
risposta è no io ho avuto una grande
fortuna nella vita una grandissima
fortuna quello di trovare la mia strada
la propria strada si trova in tanti modi
ognuno ha la sua io avevo frequentato di
università contemporaneamente perché
realtà ne cercava una terza che non
esisteva quando l'ho fatta io e quindi
ne ho fatte due contemporaneamente
però il destino mi ha riservato una
bella sorpresa cioè di poter fare la mia
università quella che non avevo trovato
per cui qualche anno dopo aver finito
queste ed università contemporaneamente
una delle due mi ha chiamata perché era
in gravi difficoltà e ha chiamato me per
salvarli non mi chiedete perché perché
io lavoravo in una grande agenzia di
corporate brand image con sede in italia
nel resto del mondo quando mi hanno
chiamato sono chiamata sono andata
questa per me era stata un cambiamento
epocale su quelle università mi aveva
cambiato la vita perché in fondo era la
direzione che stava intraprendendo o che
avrei voluto
e allora poi non mi hanno chiesto aiuto
anche se erano una posizione invidiabile
eccetera eccetera eccetera
mi sono fatto una domanda che poi è
quella che ho sempre fatto ai miei
studenti a chi mi ha chiesto consigli
nella vita eccetera eccetera
che cos'è cos'è era importante per me
che cosa mi rendeva felice
quell'università mi aveva reso molto
felice
e quindi ho risposto di sì
e qualche volta
spesso secondo me è un giudizio di parte
le scelte più importanti della nostra
vita
le facciamo
per coraggio
io non ero un esperta di education e io
mi occupavo di design della
comunicazione di grandissimi brand
eccetera eccetera però quando mi ha
fatto questa domanda mi si è aperto il
cuore
per cui mi sono licenziata da un un
posto incredibile che chiunque avrebbe
voluto
mi sono senza dire giustamente
da mio padre in particolare che stavo
facendo l'errore più grande della mia
vita che sarei finita a fare l'operatore
ecologico
adesso ad un momento terribile perché
mentre io ero entusiasta felice c'è
interesse per tutti erano disperati
beh subito ci sono rimasta molto male
potete immaginare ma subito dopo con un
passo avanti rispetto a tutte queste
critiche ho preso la decisione di
licenziarmi di intraprendere
quello che era il mio sogno quello che
avevano il cuore che mi era capitato non
avrei mai pensato che quella sarebbe
stata la mia strada per ora è stata
quindi mi sono licenziato e ho comprato
muscolari design non solo una figlia
d'arte
l'ho comprata perché aiutare qualcuno
che era di un'altra generazione città
era complicato e quindi sono stata
fortunata prima mi sono detta posso
vivere un anno senza lavorare se ho
sbagliato ho sbagliato pace e santa
miseria
vuol dire che tra un anno tornerò nel
mio settore
vedremo
non avevo sbagliato e quindi il coraggio
di prendere quella decisione mi ha
cambiato la vita ma non l'ha cambiata
solo a me l'ha cambiata migliaia di
studenti il mio sogno era realizzare
l'università che non avevo trovato una
volute far due e poi due master e
eccetera eccetera
è in vent'anni sono riuscito a
realizzarla quindi ho comprato la mia
piccola scuola di design chi mi aveva
dato grandi soddisfazioni e la o
trasformata
in una grande università internazionale
che faceva parte diventata parte
integrante di un grandissimo gruppo il
più grande in questo momento d'europa
e questo vi amore profondo e durato 20
anni
l'immagine che vedete qui dietro è di un
ex studente talentuosissimo che in
questo momento è in giro per il mondo il
file art director in una grandissima
agenzia di comunicazione quando arriva
mi ricordo tanti di questi studenti
eccezionali che arrivavano a 18 19 anni
senza sapere di essere eccezionale ma
sapendo di avere qualcosa questo
qualcosa è quello che ha contraddistinto
la vita di molti di quelli che hanno
trovato la propria strada quasi per caso
lui venne da me l'università e mi disse
insomma parlammo in generale e vedi se
ho un problema grossissimo io voglio
occuparmi di comunicazione nella mia
vita e il mio sogno voglio andare a
lavorare in grandissima agenzie ma un
problema
non sono di più amato
ma se hai un problema però possiamo ed
era si vedono negli occhi sul talento
nostro come dirlo dopo 20 anni a me
viene da dire di questo allora gli
facciamo un patto perché non si può
entrare università senza un diploma non
sapete bene io ti do un anno se tu entro
quest'anno ti diplomi e superi tutti gli
esami del primo anno io ti ha buono il
primo anno si può fare in italia si
possono riconoscere 60 crediti un
concetto un po ampi e lui accettò non
solo si diplomo si laureo eccetera ma
oggi è un grandissimo creativo nel mondo
l'altro giorno ha pubblicato questa foto
glielo rubata cioè in sé stesso me l'ha
mandata e questo è ma questo successo
per tanti studenti e per tante persone
il coraggio è quello che fa sì che
persone normali come me
facciano cose speciali che quindi
riescano in qualche modo a incidere sul
futuro proprio e di tante persone gli
studenti che io ho avuto l'onore di
aiutare a diventare dei grandissimi
professionisti ma soprattutto di
raggiungere realizzare i propri sogni
sono tanti migliaia migliaia
e questi erano ragazzi che entravano
all'università con delle grandi speranze
sogni eccetera a cui
tanti dicevano sì creativi insomma è mio
figlio è un po così e creativo ma non sa
veramente cosa vuole fare ingegneria non
ce la farebbe
proviamo
hanno raggiunto dei risultati
incredibili sono di questo è un
frequentatore su scuola non come l'oro
ad alcune hanno raggiunto la mente degli
stati meravigliosi
però il futuro perché si realizzi ha
bisogno di presenza cioè noi possiamo
cambiare le cose realizzare qualcosa di
speciale di eccezionale solo se ci
crediamo davvero
e soprattutto se ci siamo perché un
conto è parlare io oggi sono qualche
carro con voi per me è facile ma lo
faccio dopo vent'anni di cose pratiche
realizzate
e bisogna esserci non si può solo
parlare poi dopo quando si è finito di
parlare bisogna farle le cose io volevo
realizzare l'università che non c'era
non è che l'ho detto dopo tanto tempo
per dirlo fatta volevo portare una
piccola realtà di arte contemporanea
esterna più grande l'ho fatta volevo un
aiutare museo della nazionale del cinema
in un momento di difficoltà mi hanno
chiamato l'ho fatto poi si parla prima
si fa però il contrario è un'altra cosa
parlare della propria esperienza e un
conto parlare che meraviglioso se non è
che non ci sia bisogno tensione c'è di
parlare di parole di pensieri c'è sempre
bisogno ma se poi a un pensiero
importante perché i nostri gitanti
pensiero importanti continuo a sentire
la mia vita personale e professionale si
arricchisce non segue un azione
altrettanto importante è un peccato a me
fa arrabbiare questa maniera perché tra
il dire e il fare c'è di mezzo una
scelta che è quella di esserci e avere
le competenze per fare quello di cui si
parla le cose non si fanno da soli al
mondo si fanno con tante persone si
fanno con un pensiero costruito
strutturato complesso superando le
difficoltà non posso dirvi che in 20
anni non ha avuto difficoltà non si
lavora con le difficoltà si vive con le
difficoltà si superano difficoltà vi
faccio un esempio per tutti ci ho messo
sette anni a ottenere l'accreditamento
universitario sette anni cosa ho fatto
nel frattempo intanto ci credevo cos'ha
fatto nel frattempo comitato il sostegno
alla candidatura 100 aziende 200 aziende
300 aziende 400 0 sono entrata in questa
piccola realtà con un'azienda sono
uscita con 5mila
volevo farlo l'ho fatto le cose non si
fanno da sole ma si fanno essendoci io
ho scelto di iniziare e finire delle
avventure importanti che hanno cambiato
la vita la vita degli altri tutte le
volte che si parla di futuro mi fa
piacere venire a parlarne perché io sono
una che si tiene a realizzarlo e ho un
amore nel cuore perché questo è
importante ho un amore per le
generazioni future i due figli e molti
di voi immagino abbiano figli
e credo che il nostro meglio sia sempre
per le generazioni future che le
generazioni future e quindi i nostri
figli meritino tutto il nostro meglio in
qualsiasi condizione in qualsiasi
momento oggi come tutte le altre volte
che sono state chiamate a parlare io
sono qui per questo è quello che dico a
tutti e penso in questo sia veramente
l'unico pensiero che tolto tutto
continua a rimanere valido oggi e sempre
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]